Film Courage: People who wait for a filmmaking
career will never have one? Without of course
naming any names, can you think of some people
in your life who are very talented but who
are waiting? Maybe this frustrates you? Maybe
you see the opportunity in front of them but
they won’t take it for whatever reason?
Kenneth Castillo, Filmmaker: Yes, mostly colleagues.
I won’t even say friends, just people that
you run into. But what I’ve come to realize
is that (particularly those filmmakers who’ve
come out of film school) you are not going
to have a crew of 30 on your next film. They
come outwith these great thesis films and
they want to get their feature made. But in
this age of independent filmmaking, no one
is going to give you a million dollars to
do your thesis film.
And when I don’t see them working or trying
to start from scratch whether it’s a feature
film (whatever it is) to continue to do the
craft until you get that. I’m not saying
it’s not possible but I’m really blown
away by filmmakers I know that have a great
thesis film from film school and are waiting
to make their feature film. I’m like “Why
aren’t you doing something now?” “I
don’t want to film something on my phone.
I don’t want to shoot something with a three-person
crew.” I’m like “What are you waiting
for?”
It’s not something I can tell people. You’ve
got to figure that out on your own. But if
you’ve been 10 years now (and I know filmmakers
that are 10 years out of film school) still
thinking they are going to get 3 million dollars
to produce their first film based off of their
thesis.
Film Courage: Why do you think this is? Do
you think they feel they’re at a different
status level? They don’t want people...they
want to have investors?
Kenneth: I think it’s a combination of that
and people in this industry. I think everyone
looks at their trajectory going like this
[consistent upward line] and it doesn’t.
You started with a thesis and you have a crew
of thirty and all of this millions of dollars
worth of equipment that the school provides
for you. You get out, do you really want to
film your short movie on an iPhone? The ones
that work do. Because that’s ego. In my
experience having done as much as I’ve done
what I’ve found is there are certain film
schools (and I’ve hired certain film school
students)...but I won’t say the ones where
they have the least discipline but the ones
with the MOST discipline have come from the
Los Angeles Film School. They have come with
the discipline to work. It didn’t matter
how good their thesis film was. If my crew
was small or whatever, they wanted to work,
they wanted to learn and they wanted to produce.
Film Courage: I know there’s a lot of backlash
on Millennials that they don’t want to work
and things like that. I haven’t always seen
this. I’ve seen work ethics differ across
many generations (even in Generation X I’ve
seen varied work ethics). Do you think it’s
generational or a mindset?
Kenneth: It’s definitely a mindset, I don’t
find it generational at all. If this is what
you want to do, you’re going to do it and
you’re going to do it as often as you possibly
can. The thing I say to people who want to
be writers, you have to be writing everyday.
If you want to be a director or filmmaker,
you should be trying to make something or
shoot something every month, every week if
you can, but at least every month.
It’s a craft, it’s like building a deck.
The first step you build is not going to be
as fancy or as good. But the more you do it
the better you get at it. And filmmaking is
no different so I don’t really subscribe
to that philosophy of “Well I’m waiting
for this. I’m waiting for the right money,
I’m waiting for the right people.” No.
I’m not a subscriber to that. You just kind
of have to go forward. If that’s all you’re
banking on, if that’s all you have is that
one script that you want to make perfect,
you’re going to have a difficult time.
Film Courage: Do you think the DIY mindset...because
there are certain people who are really self-generating,
they just do, they rely on themselves. They
don’t expect any handouts and they just
want to do something themselves. Whereas there
are others where maybe they’ve had more
coddling or whatever there is, do you think
that there’s a clash? Do you think those
two mindsets clash?
Kenneth: Only on a panel. Yes because to me
it just comes down to the work. Can you produce?
So it can...there are certain filmmakers we
follow. I think filmmakers try to model their
careers after other filmmakers. That’s not
something I’ve ever done. I’ve never looked
at someone and said “This is how I’m going
to do it like they did. Or “I’m going
to do this and this is how it’s going to
happen.” My thing has always been just how
do I get my stuff made right now?
If I wrote a ten million dollar script I would
have it but that wouldn’t be the first thing
I would try to get made. I would have a fifty
thousand dollar script. I would have a ten
thousand dollar script. I would have different
things. What can I do right now? And if that
does take, what do I have back here that is
ready to go?